hey you guys what's going on it's Monday
night and we're talking about movies
yeah this is an interesting movie this
was an this was interesting how this
came about us watching this yeah because
I remember you telling me about it a
long time ago because your first wife
was real into this movie and showed it
to you yeah she showed it to me and
[__] um I liked it first time I saw
it I was on acid yeah I thought I
thought everybody was midgets in it at
first when he told me that when it
started I was like oh my God that's
hilarious I'm like should we watch this
on acid yeah she she explained the whole
time I was watching it I was like what
would this be like on acid yeah now I
kind of want to watch it on acid and it
blew my mind on
acid I I can see that then I saw it
again sober like the next day right I
said I want to see that again you know
and saw it again and it it's a good
movie
um it had that dude in it Billy Zayn
yeah Billy Zayn I mean he's on the cover
but he's only in it for like five
minutes yeah my ex-wife was just totally
in love with Billy Zayn she'd be
watching that sh
drooling like I wasn't a hater though
back then I just like yeah okay it's
like all right I get it yeah well he's
in he's in a real good scene with in
this he's a cool character so I
understand why she got a crush on Billy
Zayn from this movie yeah he cool he
looked he's not my super type but I but
he does look cool in this one like he
looks like um like he should be on the
cover of like a revolutionary era like
romance Noob like he had like all the
hair and he's got those lips and the big
like floofy shirt and everything and I'm
just kind of like all right all right
hisse around and his Victor sure so he
look cool um what's weird about this
movie is it's almost kind of
like don't get me wrong now okay it's
almost kind of like vampire adjacent
story it's about this character well
he's an immortal yeah it's about this
character named
Orlando who became Immortal because
somehow the Queen of England back in the
1400s told him not to grow old Elizabeth
the first Elizabeth the first yeah he
was Elizabeth the First the favorite
yeah mascot it was just this pretty boy
who had badass calves and he would just
lay up and bed with the queen queen just
rub on his calves and [__] it
was right but the Orlando is not played
by a man though Orlando's played by a
woman till this wion yeah she looks
great in it I love told this wh she is
[__] awesome she's one of the best
actors going today I
right and as Orlando ages [__] happens
to him and it's very much about like
gender roles and gender expectations for
men over the
centuries and for women too and for
women later yeah cuz
he he fails so badly at being a man he
actually somehow transforms into a woman
he really transforms into a woman for
real I don't think that's necessarily
because I did a lot of research about
the novel that this is based on and all
this other kind of stuff and I'm not
entirely sure that that's exactly what
it was now I will say that the movie is
is different than the novel but not a
lot different it still kind of captures
the spirit of she have children yeah
yeah so the movie implies that she
biologically became a woman they show
her and she was biologically a female
well and there's no yeah and I like that
it's weird that you were the one that
show me this movie because that was one
of the few movies I showed her that she
yeah because I've seen everything this
one yeah and I had never seen that one
either and I was like holy [__] how did
I miss this one and this was another one
that should have been into I should have
yeah and it's and the thing about it was
this came out in
1992 it's a British film and I was
watching a [__] ton of movies in the 90s
and especially British movies because I
love British movies and I love period
dramas I love anything that has to do
with like you know gender like you know
that are kind of like queer movies or
stuff like that so this should have
totally been on my radar got a lot of
gay people in the movie I think I had
heard of it but I had never watched it
for whatever reason and then like so
when we watched I'm like how the [__]
did I not watch this back then this
would have been exactly the time kind of
movie that I would have watched back in
the 1990s and I don't know how I missed
it today I think the woke people
wouldn't like this I think they'd
probably tear into it because they say
that it's like a half measure but
[__] in the 90s this movie was way
ahead of its time it was kind of like an
artistic and
intelligent [__] story
about gender expectations over the
[__] centuries over the centuries
like of British history yeah because
Orlando lived to be at least 400 years
old into the modern era and she hadn't
gotten old when she was pregnant for
[__] 70 years before she even had the
[__] she was carrying a baby what 70 80
years yeah they did imply that didn't
they yeah they implied because she they
implied that it was the American
Revolutionary that got her knocked up
yeah and then she next thing you see her
she's in World War II World War I andn
as a like running across the battlefield
running across the battlefield and then
they find then they show her in the 90s
and the kids only like few years old
yeah it's like five or six so she
carried that baby for 70 80 90 years
something like that that's got to suck
yeah but uh it's it's a light-hearted
movie it it it it's pretty interesting
it shows how you can fail as a dude
because Orlando kind of sucked as a dude
he had a lot of the same [__]
problems you see with young guys even to
the to to today I love you so therefore
our [__] I like you so therefore our
Destinies are entwined
you you belong to me that's the first
mistake he made he Mees he Russian chick
he falls for his Russian and his
daughter yeah he was born to a high
family he was a lord yeah he was a Lord
and his his his dad died so he became a
lord had a big ass
Manor and he had the he had that house
for 400
years it's just kind of a long
story he
EV he h he hires this uh after his
[__] he he he was in an arranged
relationship with uh the British chick
who was homely okay but she was wealthy
that was like marrying her was his
career he was supposed to marry
her but an ambassador from from from M
movi Russia yeah okay Moscow came over
and was trying to plead for help I guess
you know from England and um the
Ambassador brought his daughter and
she's just hot as [__] it's like a cute
little Orlando's like yeah and Orlando
[__] cucks his wife out in front of
her and goes after this man there's like
this is a very witty I'm going to say if
you liked the what is the movie that
came out a couple years ago that we saw
in the theater that I absolutely love
the favorite if you like that movie this
is kind of like a Proto that you know
what I mean it's like along the same
lines it's very very witty it has
gorgeous costumes and it's like it was
much funnier than I was expecting yeah
so he he betrays his
betrodd fiance he's like and she's like
the treachery of men yeah and then later
he's trying to hook up with this russing
chick and she's got a totally different
philosophy of life she's living in here
and now and he's trying to like you know
you're going to stay with me and he's
making all these plans and she's like
well why you know like why because I
love you and he's like uh so she gets on
the ship and she had he had this plan to
get to sneak her back off the ship I
don't remember exactly how it was when
the tide would change he'd [__] get
her off the ship yeah yeah so she didn't
have to go back to to
mcoi and [__] he hands her over to
ship and it's obvious that [__] one
of the big [__] sailor lugs that was
there handsome young guy [__] just
mooches on her just starts macking on
her on the [__] deck of the ship and
and Orlando sees it you know what I mean
and runs up on the dude and tries to
beat his ass yeah Orlando like 125 lb
this fcking 200 lb dude just I mean you
know yeah he's a girl you know who's a
very he's a very slender Orlando was not
a physical guy he was a a scholarly Rich
gentleman he was a poet he was a PO he
wanted to be a poet gets his [__] laid
out and then he goes I saw him his arms
around you this and he go oh no no it
it's your imagination she's [__]
gaslighting yeah for real yeah and then
he's like oh my God women suck right
well she never [__] meets up to the
[__] arranged meeting you know mean
that was implied that either the ship
sank or she she never came back I don't
remember what it was it's hard to say
because you saw see dead people in the
water but then he's like the treachery
of women man you just [__] over the
other that you [__] over your yeah
well you [__] over your [__] fiance
for this one and she [__] you over and
yeah then you're sitting here the
treachery of women so then he's [__]
well somehow like I said and I think
that that was kind of what they were
making a ment on is like you know the
men at the time cuz she was playing a
male character at the time it's like oh
well they feel like they get screwed
over and stuff like that but they don't
realize they were [__] over they
don't realize that they were [__]
over other people yeah he was totally uh
suffering from clipsism yeah big time
and uh so he gets all depressed and
[__] goes and sleeps for like two
weeks they're trying to wake him up all
the servants you know he didn't want to
wake up right [__] he whenever
whenever [__] Turning Point would
happened in his life he'd sleep for a
few weeks yeah and they couldn't wake
him up people couldn't understand it
right like some rip V Winkle [__] yeah
so uh he finally comes out he thinks
he's a poet he's all Grizzly and [__] he
he invites over his favorite poet the
dude's a [__] scumbag oh my God that
SC was [__] hilarious yeah yeah
Orlando's this highminded well BR
[__] Rich dude you know what I mean
the poet's just a scumbag you know he's
trying to get everything can get broke
you know so he just like wants a [__]
Patron you yeah yeah so he becomes his
Patron he [__] weasles him into like
a [__]
salary and uh he making fun of [__]
Orlando's poetry behind his back which
is terrible yeah laughing at it he
writes a poem about Orlando about how
basically he says you ain't [__] because
you're just rich and you sit around and
do nothing and you're just in a big pal
f with W you don't ever have to suffer
you don't do anything yeah just read and
you know you're just like a so [__]
his [__] he goes off [__] he sleeps
for another two weeks cuz his [__]
Idol calls him a piece of [__] you're a
rich boy you don't do nothing he gets up
and goes that's it I'm going to have an
adventure yeah so he goes off to [__]
Arabia like they said yeah they send him
like to be an ambassador there yeah to
be an ambassador to Arabia right
actually he shapes up he kind of becomes
more of a man of action a bit starts
dressing Arab he's got this Arab
friend who he's uh they bro out they
been brewing out although he's trying to
fake bro we were here to talk about the
manly virtues but Orlando doesn't know
any virtues like um yeah like uh things
you know stuff stuff yeah Orlando didn't
know any manly
virtues but see I think well like I said
I think the point of it I I want kind of
want to get like a little bit later into
the context of like the novel and you
know how How It Was Written and stuff
like that but but um I think kind of the
point of the story is that the character
of Orlando no matter what gender they
were did not conform to the expectations
of the time they did not conform to the
masculine ideals when when they were a
man and didn't conform to feminine
ideals when they were woman yeah but
from the Mass's point of view he failed
because he wasn't there for his friends
when the enemies were at the gates he he
promised him that he would be by his
side and and back him when the enemy
came for and he did at first but then as
soon as you started seeing what killing
was but then he could he couldn't yeah
no I'm not so he ran from the
battlefield right and left let his boy
die
evidently okay so that [__] him up he
slept a long time and when he woke up he
was a woman yeah basically which like I
said it's I kind of like it because it's
a period drama and like it's funny too
like it's witty but it's also like a
fantasy they don't explain now in the
book it's not explained at all why
Orlando is Immortal in the movie they
basically just give a reason oh well
Queen Elizabeth liked him so much and
said well I I will give you all of this
land and all of this money and all this
stuff like in perpetuity on the
condition that you never wither and you
never grow old and so he doesn't so he
just lives forever that's the
explanation so that's the only expl in
the book there is no explanation he's
just imortal he's just an immortal yeah
yeah because it's seen as like I said
it's like a fantasy of like just seeing
the entirety of British history like
Through The Eyes of a single character
that changes gender for for me at the
time you know this is the uh this is the
early to mid
90s this was movie to me was it was kind
of like for me interview the vampire but
it was more light-hearted kind of like a
comedy you had kind of like this
sexually ambiguous character characters
that lived a long time yeah and did [__]
you know what I mean it's kind of like
that but uh this one is uh not as dark
of course yeah this one's actually kind
of fun yeah it's a fun movie to watch
just uh Orlando was better as a woman
though if you ask me he he he made more
sense as a woman but even then like
after she became lady Orlando and then
it kind of goes through all of the all
of the problems that that entailed
because she comes back
from uh from Arabia from wherever she
was like as Ambassador and she's like oh
hey I'm lady Orlando now and everyone's
just like uh what and now they came
across like this whole legal thing
they're like oh well women can't own
property so therefore now there's all
these lawsuits because you can't own the
property anymore you have to have some
kind of a descendant or you have to have
you have to be married yeah they're like
basically you have to get married and
have a son or or you don't uh get this
property like take off you this one rich
old guy
what did he do he was about 50 60 he's
about mid maybe mid 60s right he [__]
loved her he's like somehow we were
fooled you're a woman yeah see they were
arguing that oh well they well Lord
Orlando had been a woman the whole time
and so they were like oh well you
deceived us and so yeah but like in the
context of the story no he absolutely
was a man to start with and he just
turned into woman later on but like I
said it wasn't explained but the is that
guy thought that somehow she had
deceived them that she was a woman all
along but uh he falls in love with her
and [__] and um he's filthy [__] rich
but and he's like yeah but you know
she's she's like she's like why would I
want to marry you and she goes because I
love you and he's so he's he's and it's
like flipping it back like from when she
was in love with word you know when he
was a man in was in love with the
Russian Lady yeah and he and she's like
uh was like all possessive about it n
you're not really you he was too
so she she walked on that but he's like
yeah but without me you're going to lose
everything yeah and she's like I don't
give a [__]
basically um but it doesn't turn out
that way she she kind of skirts the laws
for about a Century doesn't she they
don't ever take her [__] um they do
later they do later but that would took
about a hundred years yeah yeah that
they finally took her [__] they realize
they they they declared her dead because
she could have been living that long
right that was another thing yeah they
declared her dead that you were like 200
and something years old so you got to be
dead I think in the book the guy that
proposed marriage to her I can't
remember what his name was I think in
the book he started out as a woman and
also changed his gender if I'm not if
I'm remembering correctly so was he was
aortal he was an immortal too yeah well
and that's the thing like I said it
didn't really explain like because some
of the characters because the critic um
or the um the poet that she brought to
the uh house and was like when was Dick
and was a dick to her and like you know
[__] on her poetry and everything um in
the book that guy also turns up later on
like in the modern day which the book
came out in 1928 so um all right so he
came up in 192 so he was an immortal an
immortal too but like I said it's just
kind of like nobody really explained
they weren't vampires or nothing like
that they were just Immortal just
because some people didn't die like they
didn't explain it and so they turned up
in different which I kind of like like I
said it's just kind of like it's almost
like magical realism yeah I guess like
that kind of thing yeah the story just
basically proposes that some people can
basically live forever in slow motion
they AG in very slow said it's like
magical realism and then they somehow
can in in moments of Crisis change their
sex
spontaneously well and interestingly the
one thing she said and there's a great
scene where when she wakes up as lady
Orlando like after being asleep for
however long she was asleep and then she
wakes up and she looks at herself in the
mirror like with you know naked like as
with a woman's body and she basically
said same person just a different
different sex that's what she says so
like I said now the interesting thing
about this okay so this is based on a
quite a well-known novel by Virginia
wolf which came out in 1928 which was
called Orlando a
biography and in the movie they kind of
um you know the the book is a lot more
sprawling like a lot more [__] happens
um you know it takes place like over
hundreds of years so they had to like
trim some stuff out just for the sake of
brevity or whatever um but the thing
about it is that Virginia wolf was an
interesting uh person she's
probably um one of the most important uh
modernist writers of the 20th
century another thing too is that she
was a member of what do they call the
the bloomberry group or whatever they
called it um who were all very and you
know you you have to think this was the
early 20th century yeah um um it was a
group of people that were not real happy
with um you know gender strictures so a
lot of them were gay or bisexual or
whatever Virginia wolf herself uh she
was married to a man who she seemed to
love but um she was not big on sex with
men uh she had relationships with a lot
of women during her life and Orlando was
actually based on her girlfriend at the
time whose name was Vita Sackville West
now Vita Sackville West had almost the
same thing happened to her that happens
to Orlando in the movie where she had an
ancestral estate called null and she did
not inherit it she lost it because she
didn't have any male heirs and there
were no male heirs and she was only a
female and they would not give it to her
so that was kind of one of the things
that I think inspired Virginia wolf to
write this story so a lot of the stuff
that happens in the story to Orlando
actually happened to her girlfriend at
the time Vita Sackville West so it's
based on
that woman Loosely uh the character is
so like I said and Vita actl West was
also a member of this group that was
like I said they were kind of more into
what they would call like gender
fluidity or they were just kind of
raging against uh you know gender
strictures at the time like expectations
of like certain genders they didn't
really love that so there's a lot of
that in this movie you know in the sense
that
Orlando
you know make statements throughout the
thing where it's just like whether the
character is a man or a woman it's still
the same person like they personality
Remains the Same they remain the same
person whatever yeah but like I said
they that's what they're proposing I
mean yeah you could say that that's true
but a lot these people that are writing
this this is long before synthetic
hormones they don't
realize that it's not just the body the
body all that that dictates gender the
body no matter what you know if you're
male or female some people are actually
kind of a little bit in between there's
which is kind of a weird
phenomenon but you're also producing
hormones that dictate who you are um but
they they haven't really experienced
that I [__] give all kinds of [__]
hormones in my body make you hyper
[__] masculine where you want to kill
people and [__] and uh real [__]
aggressive and then or sometimes you
just get flooded with progesterone which
just makes you simpy and like it's time
to build the nest you know what I mean
and just Weir weird [__] you know so
they're only seeing part of the picture
there's it's not just
physical build it's also [__] the
hormones that are flooding through you
change your
personality so I don't know why these
people went off in that direction you
know I don't know maybe it was hormone
levels or or what
but you can't just change somebody's
body and they're the same person that
doesn't actually happen yeah but I think
put me in a female body I'll become a
female because the hormones that body
makes well like I said I think the whole
point of the story because like she
wrote it as kind of like a fantasy and
she wanted to
explore centuries of British history
Through The Eyes of you know how it
would be from a a man's perspective and
how it would be from a woman's
perspective but also trying to make the
point that yeah it would be different
from those perspectives but maybe not
that different you know what I mean
because she was very into what today
they would call gender fluidity yeah so
she was trying to make the point that
it's like oh it wouldn't be that much
different even though um you know the
culture of the time would perceive you
differently and you would be treated
differently so she was kind of trying to
show that too um but what I saw
something like oh John Smith said I love
this film went in expecting something
like Highlander and was surprised to say
the least who said this Highlander who
said this John Smith oh yeah some
because somebody was talking about
Highlander before this is nothing like
Highlander it's really nothing like high
it's a lot it's a lot uh more elevated
the quality is better it's like a
serious type movie but it's comedy cost
a real high quality like not a like
funny haha comedy but like a droll
comedy yeah yeah it it's uh it it's it's
filmed really well the costumes are
fantastic the acting is really good in
it uh there's no B movie elements to
this it's a a real classy flick I put it
on par in terms of production
with Interview with the Vampire you know
it's as good as that this actually got
nominated for an Academy Award for best
costume design in one other one but I
can't remember what the other topic was
a lot of good 1400s costumes 1700s
costume or 1600s 16 oh that's it starts
in starts in 1600 it starts in 1600 yeah
yeah that's right when Orlando is
presumably in his 20s I'm guessing yeah
um and it goes right up until the
present day which the book does as well
I believe the book also starts in the
Elizabethan era now the book obviously
because it came out in 1928 only goes up
to the modern day of 1928 but same kind
of thing um but this one goes up until
the
1990s so you know just like at the end
also I want to say Jimmy Somerville from
bronsky beat and uh the communards is in
this uh he's in it as like he sings at
the beginning yeah and then he an angel
and then yeah like at the end he's like
an angel and it's like and it's super
cheesy and super awesome I love when saw
I was on assd I was like what the [__]
she she using a video camera and she's
looking up and this dude flies up next
to the tree and he's got his [__]
wings and he looks like a drawing kind
he's singing sing and it's actually a
pretty good song yeah that he's singing
well I've always really liked bronsky
beat and the comar so I like Jimmy zille
yeah and that was the end of it so I
thought it was kind of cool that he was
in that he was in it and John Smith also
points out also Quinton crisp as Queen
Elizabeth the what more do you need
exactly yeah that's Quinton Chris um he
is actually very famous uh gay icon uh
writer humorist uh various other things
and um yeah so they he's Queen Elizabeth
in this and it's great I mean he's
really only in like the beginning part
you know what I mean because like this
jumps ahead like it starts in 1600 and
then it jumps ahead like in 50y year
yeah you know he plays que Queen
Elizabeth as an old lady yeah and she's
at the into her life and uh you can't
tell if she's a man or woman I'm going
Jen is that is that that's a dude isn't
that a man she go I was like yeah I'm
like pretty sure like he looks real
familiar but yeah it's Quenton Crisp
that's right but you could at that age
you there are women that look like that
yeah you know there are that was hard
for me to tell wait you become less
hormonal so you don't have secondary sex
characteristics as you get age as you
get older if you're not [__] ejecting
hormones so that's that's part of the
the Aging process um but that like I was
saying before J Jen was talking about
gender fluid people if when I look at
the gender fluid people man they don't
to me they don't look very hormonal I
could take one of them dudes to just
start banging him up with a bunch of
test he'd become a beast and he' just be
a man and he' be probably be a dick too
so or hormones do dictate who you are uh
I didn't believe it until I experienced
it myself if you were to [__] pull my
mind out or give a brain transplant put
me in a female body under the influence
of those hormones over a few years i' I
would just become a
woman CU that's what would feel right in
that body making that hormonal package
be attracted to dudes and
stuff yeah I mean but that's kind of the
thing I've always been interested I
would love to be a dude for a
day maybe just a day I don't I don't
know if I could stand it long got stuff
here that'll make you feel like it but
thing is start growing a
beard yeah I don't know you'd be hanging
out with me and [__] trying to fight
people and
[__] arguing over cars so maybe that's
not such a time for us to rebuild this
engine like in some like like I said I'm
curious about what it would be like but
then in some ways like you talk about it
I'm like nah it doesn't it doesn't
really sound that fun
actually sounds kind of lame so it's
like Maybe not maybe not I don't know
maale mind you become very mechanic
mechanic uh mechanistic you're kind of
like a machine like uh your emotions are
not quite the same um more logic
dominated which is kind of like a sparse
way of thinking things are real direct
women don't tend to like
it a guy has to kind of control how he
behaves around women because you're
going to do things that they don't
because women women don't think like
that they don't feel like the way guys
do it's and a good a good uh thing to go
there have been Fe female to
male um transsexuals that have
transitioned into into being a man and
you look at them hormonally you'd never
know that that was a woman and her just
beard and everything and um a lot of
them don't like it I want some of them
want to go back but some of them
eventually adap adapt to it they said
it's they basically say that it's very
lonely compared to what women experience
interesting they just very lonely
everybody avoids you you're walking down
the street people go well yeah because
you're a threat to them so is you feel
very lonely and isolated but guys don't
notice it because we grew up that way
yeah because you don't know any
different we notice it but well see
that's why I'm kind of fascinated I've
read a couple of books um by people who
transitioned and it's really interesting
to see like a perspective from both
sides of the coin you know what I mean
like people that have experienced both
things because I haven't so it's like I
don't know what it's like to be a dude
um you know what I mean like I can
imagine it but I can't internalize it
you know cuz I've never I didn't grow up
that way I wasn't treated that way you
know I've always been you know female so
it's just but it's interesting to me to
get those people's perspectives on that
it really is interesting and I never
heard that that anybody said that it was
like lonely that's that's fascinating
say real lonely that's fascinating I've
heard it from two different wands huh
they said that that would have never
occurred to me but I can see it much
much fewer friends right that women have
lots of friends and they tend to yeah
well women tend to be more social
generally yeah well the you transition
into a guy I'm not and you're a
convincing guy yeah their friends all
dry up they all go away and then people
don't want to sit next to them in the
bus they go across the street and people
[__] go around them you know what I
mean because they especially women women
kind of avoid them well yeah because
you're a threat you're right yeah so the
I don't sit next to random ass dudes on
the bus and then like yeah and then like
uh they'll say that
as a as a female they would have a dozen
friends but as a guy they might have
one yeah okay and and most guys who was
experience it man you guys can drop it
in the [__] comment section most guys
only have like maybe one or two good
male
friends yeah and and a lot of dudes
never really have friendships with women
especially if you're not attractive now
you might have some friendships with
women that are like your mom or you know
what I mean aunts or friends of the
but in terms of females who aren't
related to you if you're not interesting
to them they don't want anything to do
with
you well we've talked about this before
because I said one I think in general
and like I said this is a generalization
obviously everyone's uh experience is
going to be different but I've always
found that female friendships were much
closer and much deeper than male
friendships were um male friendships
tended to be more superficial I thought
and like I said that's just a
generalization I'm sure that's not true
across the board male friendships are
usually forged in their teenage years
you keep those for right anything after
that you don't really you don't need
them so you don't really contact them
that much yeah and our conversations and
relationships usually have to do with
trading information yeah like I said
kind of just surface level kind of but
we don't find that superficial yeah we
find that real practical like oh yeah
yeah he said this and that man he told
me about this yeah well he sent me one
of these I'm going to send him this it's
not really emotion based it's more like
utility based yeah right that's a good
way of putting it yeah it makes a lot
more sense for us right yeah yeah I'm
not saying it's wrong or anything like
that I'm just saying it's different
right and um he got my back do that that
you know it's just that and another
thing we talked about too and in
relation to you and relation to like um
you know kind of why a lot of maybe why
some dudes aren't successful with women
like romantically is because they don't
have any friendships with women that are
not sexual you know what I mean they
they don't have any genuine friendships
with women I think the average guy can't
can't really achieve that that's what I
mean and that's really interesting
because like I said you have a lot of
friends that are I mean you have a lot
of male friends you have a lot of female
friends and I have more female friends
than male friends you probably do yeah
um you know what I mean and and that's
really interesting cuz I feel like a lot
of guys don't have that it's almost like
they can't can't
separate they can't take sex out of the
equation is that what is am I right
about that no no what it is is that the
average guy is invisible to most women
hypergamy is happening women really are
only are only going to Rea interact with
the top 20% of the men that they
see see right but why would you want to
interact and be friends with the average
guy you avoid those if he comes up to
you in the bar you like n no no thanks
Cuz women reject most men just off the
cuff off the cuff yeah but that's just
because you think they're trying to get
in your pants there you go thank you but
like I said Thank you and well and nine
times out of 10 that's what they're
trying to do and you're like man well
they're at least they're trying to have
some kind of interaction but I don't
know even when I was growing up I had a
lot of friends that were dudes when well
in the adult world I guess you could say
at the time I still have a lot of
friends that are D yeah yeah I don't
sleep with them or find them sexually
attractive or anything like that but
those guys are pretty acceptable though
I guess yeah all right they're not
average the average guy is invisible
basically to
women and the average woman is Not
Invisible to the average
guy some guys will date
down
yeah you know so it's not really the
same we're getting off topic well I mean
we're kind of talking about this movie
is about gender politics yeah so we are
kind of talking about that I just I'm
just proving it over and over again I
the data is out there I mean I haven't
proved other people proved it that the
average guy's an
inel on a global
scale he has no
chance that's why the guys are
disposable it's why you throw them in
the meat grinder war that they're
working down in
mines cleaning out sewers and [__]
working at the garbage dump that's where
most of them more that's where your
average one
is it's a bleak life it's very
Bleak but to be fair like I just across
their jeans down I've seen some dudes
that looked just hideous and they were
paired off so that didn't matter though
they were something about him that made
him not
average I guess but like I said also it
changes there's different also different
stages in men's lives yeah that's some
of them can
be successful when they're young but
then in the middle age they're not
successful anymore right uh or it could
be the other way around when they were
young there wasn't anything there but
now they're middleaged they're more
successful now they got kind of got
their [__] now they got their [__]
together they might even look better now
and have more money now than they did
back then so the stage of development is
all different it's across the board
John Smith said I like to think Orlando
becomes Immortal just because Queen
Elizabeth commanded him not to yeah well
I think like I said in the book there
was no reason for Orlando being
essentially Immortal um so in the movie
uh the writer director who was Sally
Potter um she was like well you know in
a movie you kind of have to have like a
little bit of a [__] reason like CU
there wasn't a reason in the book so
they thought it would be funny to just
have him be immortal just because Queen
Queen Elizabeth said don't ever get old
like that's the condition for you having
this property and money and everything
like that and he was just kind of like
okay I won't and he didn't you know what
I mean so it's like I just I just like
that they just kind of left it at
that John Smith also says a great writer
on male friendship and I will die on
this hill Stephen King he actually is
very good he's good at relationships in
general but particularly in conveying
male friendships he does seem to be very
very good at that um sometimes and he's
actually like um one of the better male
writers when it cames when it comes to
writing like female characters uh cuz
sometimes you know especially in the
horor genre which I read a lot of like a
lot of male writers they write a female
character and I'm just kind of like okay
but um it's like we don't think like
that but all right but Stephen King has
actually generally been pretty good at
that but I do think that his strength is
male characters and particularly like um
friendships between male characters like
really deep friendships he seems to be
really good at that yeah Tammy says uh
personality is she wres like really big
yeah yeah but a personality can Elevate
the average looking guy to somebody
that's what she means that's what she
means so you're not really average
anymore yeah there's a okay here's the
thing men score women totally physically
one to 10 and that one to 10 is going to
be physical women don't do that women
give guys kind of like an overall score
what's his status how much is he making
what does he look like what's his
personality like does it make it's a lot
more criteria is he funny is
he so you see a guy physically he might
be a three but he's actually actually at
the level of seven because he's got a
good personality he's got money and he's
entertaining yeah like I said somebody
being like funny and confident and stuff
like that I mean that goes a long way
yeah and if you got status like you're a
like you're a celebrity you're going to
move up so women like
status U which just the way it is they
find that's like an aodc for women if a
guy's a celebrity that really
helps uh You' have to be a real [__]
[__] to [__] that up and they got
dudes that can celebrities that they
[__] it up they can't get laid yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah so that just goes to show
that I mean women do have standards it's
like as rich and famous as you may be uh
you can be enough of a dick to have
women be like nope like [__] that dude
no thank you you know what I mean all
that [__] amount of money all that [__]
just gets you in the door once you're in
the door then you got to [__] perform
if if not then well we've talked about
this before like even dudes that are
super good-look or super jacked or they
can fail so yeah because you know yeah
they might get a date yeah you know but
then the girl like talks to them and
they're just kind of like man this dude
kind of Lan although dudes kind of do
the same thing because I in the past
over the years I've landed women that I
probably put it physically a
nine but they were just so terrible
usually in bed they're so terrible in
bed you move them down to like a six
yeah starfish out on you like the no
effort at all like she's doing you a
favor and I what the [__] is this and
that's it I'm call her back you know
yeah so she looks good but's across the
board nothing there um you know I'm not
going to deny that if you look good
obviously you have advantages yeah but
you have to also have something to back
that up yeah because if you don't you're
not going to get a lot of second and and
and in my no matter how good you look
and in my
experience very attractive women tend to
be like the worst
ones uh very low effort annoying
personalities because they've been
skating on looks well they're allowed to
get away with a lot because they're
because they're cute and dudes will put
up with it because they're hot you know
what I mean but they only put up with it
for so long they get bored with them
real quick they're like this this
bitch's
annoying I mean and she can't [__] you
know I
mean so you know I don't give a [__]
what my friends think of her that's well
there's some of that in there too and
yeah you know like I don't give a [__]
what these dudes think of her man it's
boring that's well yeah like I said
that's why like good looks are you know
that does get you in the door and you do
get treated better but you no you really
do have to have something to back that
up because if you don't like right yeah
you might you might get a lot of dates
you might get laid a lot but nobody's
going to hang around but just because a
woman's beautiful doesn't mean she's a
piece of [__] we've showed her before we
got some friends bad [__] with Jenny's
[__] awesome looking [__] some of
our friends [__] Jen and [__] um
Laura those girls are
[__] cute as [__] man and they're
they're great personalities especially
Laura Laura's just a good person yeah
you know you can hang out with her and
she's totally reasonable and you know
she's not [__] or anything like that
so I've heard some of these guys on the
internet just really kind of like
generalize beautiful women because they
don't know them they just know a few
that they run into that were [__]
just teenagers or in their 20s and [__]
no they got some good women that look
great I mean and I will admit like some
beautiful women are shitty not yeah but
honestly I in my experience and maybe
this is just because we're kind of more
in a subculture or whatever but I've
known like a lot more really beautiful
women that were just like really cool
people they're just nice people you know
what I mean so sometimes you see a chick
she's ugly on the inside and the outside
yeah you got that too so just you well
that's what I mean you can't ever judge
can't really can't you can't ever really
judge just by like what people look like
you know what I mean there's a lot of
different kind of [__] going on out
there
um yeah okay Danny says Errol Flynn the
actor fouled up all his marriages by
cheating and was the inspiration for
Neville Sinclair in The Rocketeer film
just saying yeah Errol Flynn am I
thinking of underage girls too well yeah
I think he bought an underage girl from
her from their parents I had heard that
as well yeah I need to look that story
up I'm not sure he had a mirror he he
had a [__] two-way
mirror in the ceiling so his friends
could watch him
[__] they take turns well he sounds
like a real piece of [__] doesn't he
yeah over the bad and [__] some weird
[__] and I'm sure and I'm sure whoever
was [__] did not consent to that oh
yeah they probably didn't know no and
didn't know yeah that's that's pretty
shitty Errol Flynn I know you're they
were all taking turns on her and she was
like
16 that's the story that sounds like
some [__] that they would do yeah that's
the story
yeah got her from her parents people are
terrible some weird [__] man I mean yeah
at least that shit's like not acceptable
now I feel like back then it wasn't
acceptable back then I mean it wasn't
really acceptable back then but I kind
of feel like they'd let it slide more
back then than they would now what it
was is Hollywood owned the the local
cops you could do anything if you were a
celebrity holy crap you guys you were in
we we've already people got murdered
they you could kill people and the
[__] cop they get you out the studios
would get get you out of it uhhuh and
the cops would
like the Hollywood Studios were the
income that the cops had had built
themselves on they couldn't attack the
studios the Studios owned the police
basically so if you were a big celebrity
you killed somebody they'd cover it up
yeah big time and then the [__]
Studios had spread that money around
inside the police
department yep yeah just just keep this
quiet
boys yeah yeah Denny said 14,000 women
he got with supposedly how many is that
per year somebody do the math it said he
would take he would he he was big into
was he doing like a bunch of them at
once or he was big into underage with
women like between girls which
is 12 to 16 he like that age group he'd
take three or four of them at a time out
onto his Yachts he had these Yachts he
take them out with cocain get high
they'd all have sex and [__] great out
there in the water I mean yeah but the
girls were up for it so that's say yeah
but they were like 13 that say something
they had all kinds of they didn't know
[__] Star Struck I guess and then they
giving them all these drugs and [__]
yeah but see well that's the thing like
look when I I don't even remember when I
was 13 years old cuz that was a long
[__] time ago but I'm just saying
like if hypothetically if I was a
13-year-old girl and somebody that I was
super into when I was 13 like I don't
know one of the members of dur Duran or
something like I'm not saying that it's
like hey if Simon Leon had like come to
me like back in the [__] ' 80s like
You' go to the cops and
said and I'm 13 years old
let me tear this up girl but like I'm 13
on Monday right I don't know any better
Jesus Christ I don't know any better and
then like later on I'd be like what the
[__] what was i n you'd be [__]
drawing hearts and [__] and having
[__] pictures above your bed hold on
yeah come on that's how it really go
down I know that's
[Laughter]
like um let's see I'm not really sure
how to pronounce your screen name
um but so I'm not going to attempt to
but it says Stephen King wrote Gerald's
Game and Dolores Clayborn in the same
year and he wrote those women so well
some have accused him of letting his
wife Tabitha write those under his name
um I had heard that and I don't we'll
see okay so him and Tabitha have been
together since what college so they've
been together like
forever and she's a writer
too I don't know if he necessarily let
her write the women characters but I'm
sure he probably ran it by her because I
think that Tabitha reads all of his
stuff like before he publishes it and as
far as I know she still does I don't
know if she I mean that's the impression
that I got so I'm sure if he wrote
something like super [__] up she'd be
like bro like what what is this like we
wouldn't say that or we wouldn't think
that or something like that so I think
it's good that he kind of has somebody
like who is also a writer um that can
maybe kind of talk him down if he comes
up with some crazy ass [__] you know
what I mean like he's you know it's not
a situation like um who's that who's the
dude the um the writer that I that I
refie his book sometimes like that
splatter Punk kind of writer oh [__] I
forgot his total I totally forgot his
name right now but that like writes just
like the complete like like writes like
an adolescent teenage boy he's dead now
but um but yeah so I kind of feel like
if she didn't write those characters
then
she probably read them and if he said
something kind of [__] up she was just
kind of like hey you might want to
change that you know what I mean cuz
they seem to collaborate a lot as far as
I know she reads all his [__] before it
gets published that was the impression
that I got you know his wife
does oh Danny Rowling said Errol Flynn
was also a spy for Germany a spy for who
for
Germany Richard Layman yeah that's what
that's what I was thinking of for some
reason his name just went back to let's
get back to the movie yeah John Smith
said Orlando was the first thing I ever
saw till the Swindon in I think this was
her first kind of mainstream movie after
being in Derek jarmon films yeah I think
it was I don't know if I'd call this
necessarily her breakout role um but
she'd kind of been I mean this is kind
of an indie film still too yeah it was
sort of wellknown because it did get
nominated for a couple of Academy Awards
but um I don't think it was like a big
hit or anything she's cute in it yeah
like I said I love her she's like she's
fantastic but I think yeah this was kind
of one of her first kind of big
roles but
um she I I don't really think and um
Sally Potter who wrote and directed this
film she had wanted to make this movie
for like forever um going back into like
the
1980s and you know producers tell her
yeah nobody wants to see that [__] blah
blah blah but she just persevered and
she kept on going and uh finally they
made it and she actually got the idea to
put Tilda swind Swinton in it she saw
her in a Stage production I don't was
she playing a man in the Stage
production too but it's like she just
really liked her kind of like
physicality and how she came like
because she comes across as like kind of
androgynous I guess so she thought she
would sort of be perfect in this role
and I agree I can't really imagine
anyone else pulling this role off in the
same way somebody you can make her look
androgynous but she's not really she's
just got an aqualine build face she of
ethereal looking yeah she when you she's
doed up she's definitely feminine she's
just kind of thin kind of tall and thin
looking and got kind of a thin face
she's pretty you know pretty you know
I'll probably put her up there with kind
of like a um who's the chick that
[__] played Ripley uh Weaver yeah
kind of rind like a sigy weaver type she
doesn't look like her but you know what
I mean sigari kind of has that kind of
just kind of tall and thin and thin and
yeah yeah I got you tall and thin and
just kind of like you said etheric
looking kind of angelic looking yeah and
interestingly Tilda went and to play I
think they somebody mentioned this
earlier she did play a vampire in um
Only Lovers Left Alive which is a great
movie if you haven't seen it John Smith
said is it terrible I knew it was
Richard Layman just from those Rec I
knew somebody would know I was like I
did a um I think I reviewed two of his
uh books I did one called come out
tonight and I did one called body rides
and I like his books they're super fun
but you have to kind of be in the mood
for them because they are just like they
are
like you know he was in his 30s or 40s
when he wrote these books but they are
very much like a teenage boy's fantasy
so it's just like whatever like with
super like super over the toop like sex
and Gore and all this other stuff and
there's [__] that happens in there that
would never ever happen in real life you
know what I mean and the way that he
writes female characters is just like
hilarious to
me um the the stuff that they do and say
is just like super super funny but it's
just like I don't know I just find it
really entertaining I guess like some
people might be offended I'm not
offended I just think it's kind of funny
but um yeah John Smith said I think her
mainstream breakthrough was in the beach
yeah that's right I knew it was like
sometime after this cuz I knew she kind
of got a lot of accolades for this movie
but that there was another one that came
out after yeah that was it who know that
me what are you doing po she's she's
apologizing she's like I'm sorry I was
going to do it but okay okay she like to
do that on her shoes but yeah don't do
it so yeah it's just like I said it's
kind of funny that you were the one that
showed me this and you just kind of
brought it up out of the blue cuz we
were like long time ago brought it up
you brought it up a long time ago and
then like the other night we were just
like laying around I was like what do
you want to watch I don't know what I
want to watch and you were like oh
you've never seen you brought it up
again you've never seen Orlando and I
was just kind of like yeah that's right
you told me about that a long time ago
let's watch that so we ended up watching
that so like I said it's just funny that
you cuz it doesn't it doesn't on its
surface seem like a movie that you would
like it seems like a movie that I would
be into but I like I had never seen it
yeah I liked it I got the show where two
movies that she never seen the loved one
which I like that movie the loved one is
about a funeral home yeah we reviewed
that one a while back that one's great
that's from the 60s from the 60s and uh
Orlando she never seen that one yeah I
never said like I said I don't know how
I missed it cuz it's exactly the type of
stuff I would have watched yeah but
there you go well cuz usually it's the
other way around like usually cuz I like
I said I've seen a lot of [__] so I'm
just com like oh you got to see this one
and you you got to see this one you know
what I mean and he hasn't seen them but
I don't know it's just it's just weird
how that happens sometimes oh and
another one you showed me that I hadn't
seen was Brimstone and tri oh yeah you
never saw that I had never seen it prior
that's right great flip that was another
one that that like I said doesn't seem
like something that you would like yeah
I saw it but
yeah but I had I had a cultured I had a
cultured past what are you talking about
[__] yeah I watched I watch good movies
don't get offended I'm not getting offed
like I'm a ly no I saw cool fck uh uh
trying to think if there's any more of
them see you seen she's seen most of the
ones that I've seen I was trying to go
back into the roll of decks and try to
yeah you gotta like pick out you got to
go pretty deep to like find some [__]
that I se she hasn't seen right you know
what I mean cuz I cuz I watched a lot of
stuff especially like like an movies and
stuff like that I'm like really into
that so you got to like dig pretty deep
to yeah if you guys haven't seen
Brimstone and traal see it it's got
stinging in it British flip yeah there
was there's a couple demon yeah there's
a couple different versions of it
because there was a version that was on
I think it was on um British TV like
play for today but then they made like a
theatrical movie of it like later so the
one we're talking about is the one from
1982 the one with sting in it which had
some of the same people from the TV
version but that what a great movie that
was now the weird thing about knocks it
out of the [__] Park he could act
well yeah I liked him in a I liked him
in the bride I know it's like like
that's like a cheesy ass movie but I
love that movie but um the weird thing
about it is that brimson and trial was
written like the the novel was um uh
Dennis Potter and I had actually read
and seen like some other dentist P like
I saw like I read the singing detective
and Pennies from Heaven and and stuff
like that so it's surprising that I
hadn't got around to that one because I
had seen some other Dennis Potter stuff
you know is there anything else on this
um I think not I think we're probably I
got to go to the store oh that's right
yeah Tom's got to go to the store got to
get some Toms man
my K me he having a problem all right
and I gotta [__] get the get the
lasagna going oh that's right yeah we
got lasagna we got to eat all right so
uh thanks everybody for dropping by this
evening uh we're going to wrap it up so
tomorrow if I have time I might do a
live stream I'm going to do a book
review because I did actually finish
reading a book today so I might review
that tomorrow it's actually called the
neighbor by London Clark uh so if you
have time to read it before I do this
stream tomorrow it's uh if you have
Kindle unlimited you can read it for
free on there like the ebook because
that's where I got it so uh so yeah I'm
going to be talking about that tomorrow
probably so hopefully you can join me
for that if not uh we'll be back on
Wednesday for the Regular Show and for
that we're going to do mythology of
dragons that's what won in the poll so
I'm excited about that so that should be
like a really fun show so thanks
everybody for dropping by this evening
uh we will see you guys again either
tomorrow or Wednesday night good night